[Music]
Science Week in Berlin I think it's a
spectacular idea and you're doing it so
well the idea is to have people from all
over the world celebrate Science in
Berlin for a couple of days it's an
exciting place for exchange of ideas and
really it's about enthusiasm for the
world and the ways in which we can make
it a better world for everyone
[Music]
you can find the events and activities
very interactive all throughout the city
throughout the week and this is very
unique here in order to make smart
public policy decisions we need the
population understand how these things
work and what the opportunities are and
what the dangers are as scientists we
have to help explain and why in science
is important to build bridges between
science society and industry
[Music]
the general public can get a glimpse of
the excitement behind science one aspect
of science is to be open we have to
discuss different ideas at some unique
opportunity
there's a lot of people from culture and
technology and business communications
that makes I think it quite unique
[Music]
[Music]
it's been incredibly stimulating oh it's
great there's so many people here from
all around the world
[Applause]
[Music]
besides me as a place to be
[Music]
you
you